♪ ♪
>> Laura: VENEZUELA WAS ONCE A
THRIVING, PROSPEROUS COUNTRY,
BUT UNDER SOCIALIST LEADERS,
GOVERNMENT'S SEIZURE OF
EVERYTHING -- NINE AND TEN
VENEZUELANS IN POVERTY.
FOODS ARE SCARCE THEY ARE FOR
STREET SEND CATS THEY IN THE
STREET.
MADURO HAS A PATENT HE'S GRIP,
LEADING TO VIOLENT.
CONGRESSMAN ILHAN OMAR, YOU
GUESSED IT, IS BLAMING US.
>> A LOT OF THE POLICIES THAT WE
HAVE PUT IN PLACE HAS KIND OF
HELPED FEED THE DEVASTATION IN
VENEZUELA, AND WE SORT OF SET
THE STAGE FOR A WHERE ARE
ARRIVING TODAY, THIS PARTICULAR
BULLYING AND THE USE OF
SANCTIONS.
>> Laura: HERE NOW, SECRETARY
OF STATE MIKE POMPEO.
MR. SECRETARY, THANK YOU FOR
BEING WITH US TONIGHT.
WHEN YOU HEAR A MEMBER OF THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES PUT THE
BLAME SQUARELY ON THE "BULLIES"
IN THE UNITED STATES, WHAT WE
ARE SEEING TONIGHT IN VENEZUELA,
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION?
>> THE NICEST THING I CAN SAY IS
IT IS UNBELIEVABLE IGNORANCE.
IT IS JUST FACTUALLY WRONG.
YOU HIT IT IN YOUR OPENING,
LAURA.
THE PROBLEMS IN VENEZUELA HAVE
BEEN YEARS IN THE MAKING, IT HAS
BEEN A SOCIALIST REGIME, AND THE
DESTRUCTION OF A WEALTHY NATION.
A NATION WITH MORE OIL RESERVES
THAN ANY OTHER COUNTRY IN THE
WORLD COME AT A BEAUTIFUL
COUNTRY WITH BEAUTIFUL
REAL ESTATE AND SHORELINES COME
ALL KINDS OF OPPORTUNITY.
FOR A MEMBER OF CONGRESS,
FRANKLY, ONE WHO SITS ON AN
IMPORTANT NATIONAL COMMITTEE,
MAKING A STATEMENT BLAMING
AMERICA IN THIS WAY, IT IS
IGNORANT AND DISGUSTING.
>> Laura: WHAT CAN YOU TELL US
TONIGHT, NOT A SUCCESSFUL
TRANSITION IN VENEZUELA.
GUAIDO WAS THE GUY, THE WORLD
COMMUNITY CHOSE, WHY IS HE THE
RIGHT ONE AT THE RIGHT TIME?
>> THE WORLD COMMUNITY HAS
AFFORDED IT, BUT THE VENEZUELAN
PEOPLE CHOSE HIM THROUGH THEIR
NATIONAL ASSEMBLY AND THE
CONSTITUTIONAL PROCESS FOR THE
MILITARY DIDN'T FRACTURE IN THE
WAY THAT WE WOULD HOPE, BUT IT
IS JUST A MATTER OF TIME.
IT IS THE CASE THAT MADURO MAY
RULE FOR A WHILE, BUT HE WILL
NOT GOVERN.
STRUCTURALLY, THERE IS NO WAY
FOR HIM TO STAY IN POWER.
IT IS TIME FOR HIM TO LEAVE, AND
MADE THE CUBANS ON RUSSIANS TO
FOLLOW HIM OUT THE DOOR.
>> Laura: WE HAVE A PROBLEM AT
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER, HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE A MONTH
BEING APPREHENDED AND RELEASED
INTO THE COUNTRY.
WHY ARE WE FOCUSING AT ALL ON
VENEZUELA?
>> WE CAN DO MORE THAN ONE THING
AT A TIME.
WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO SECURE
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER, BUT WE HAVE
HAD 3 MILLION PEOPLE, 3 MILLION
MIGRANTS LEAVE VENEZUELA, AND IT
WILL END UP SOMEWHERE -- TODAY
THEY ARE IN COLOMBIA, CHILE,
PERU, WE HAVE AN IMPORTANT
RESPONSIBILITY IN VENEZUELA.
FIRST, WE WANT TO SUPPORT
DEMOCRACY IN SOUTH AMERICA, IT
IS IMPORTANT FOR OUR VITAL
NATIONAL SECURITY INTEREST, BUT
IT IS ALSO THE CASE WHEN WE SEE
A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS LIKE THIS,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
THAT TAKING FOOD AND PROVIDING
HUMANITARIAN SUPPORT IS
SOMETHING WE SHOULD DO.
>> Laura: I WANT TO MOVE ONTO
ANOTHER TOPIC, CHINA, WHAT
YOU'VE BEEN ADDRESSING LATELY.
JOE BIDEN DOESN'T SEEM TO THINK
CHINA IS A BIG THREAT.
LET'S WATCH LET'S WATCH.
>> CHINA IS GOING TO EAT OUR
LUNCH?
COME ON, MAN.
THEY CAN'T EVEN FIGURE OUT HOW
TO DEAL WITH THE FACT THAT THEY
HAVE THIS GREAT DIVISION BETWEEN
THE CHINA SEA IN THE MOUNTAINS
IN THE EAST -- I MEET IN THE
WEST.
THEY ARE NOT BAD FOLKS, FOLKS,
BUT GUESS WHAT?
THEY ARE NOT COMPETITION FOR US.
>> Laura: I DON'T PERSONALLY
KNOW WHAT TO SAY ABOUT THAT.
CHINA, NOT A THREAT TO THE
UNITED STATES?
WHAT IS THE TRUTH THEY ARE?
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP AND OUR
ADMINISTRATION HAS TAKEN THE
THREAT FROM CHINA VERY, VERY
SERIOUSLY, VERY DIFFERENT FROM
WHAT WE JUST HEARD THERE.
>> Laura: HE'S LEADING IN THE
POLLS.
>> WE UNDERSTAND THE THREAT.
THERE IS A TRADE IMBALANCE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS TRIED TO
TAKE ON AND GET A FAIR AND
RECIPROCAL TRADE BETWEEN THE
UNITED STATES AND CHINA.
THE CHINESE ARE WORKING TO PUT
THEIR SYSTEMS AND NETWORKS
ACROSS THE WORLD SO THEY CAN
STEER STEAL YOUR INFORMATION.
YOU TALKED ABOUT THIS, WE TALKED
ABOUT A MILLION OF THEIR ETHNIC
MINORITIES BEING HELD IN
REEDUCATION CAMPS.
THIS IS STUFF REMINISCENT OF THE
1930s, PRESENTING A REAL
CHALLENGE TO UNITED STATES, AND
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS PREPARED
TO TAKE THIS ON.
>> Laura: AMERICAN HIGH-TECH
COMPANIES IN CHINA, A LOT OF
CONCERN THAT THERE HAS BEEN, I
GUESS, INADVERTENT ASSISTANCE TO
THE COMMUNIST REGIME AS THEY
SEEK TO DOMINATE PART OF THE
ROAD INITIATIVE, EVERY INDUSTRY,
INCLUDING SPACE, WEAPONRY,
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE BUT WHAT
CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THE
CONCERNS OF AMERICAN BIG TAX
GOING TO CHINA TO SET UP A
STRAP?
>> WE HAVE TO TALK TO EACH OF
THESE BUSINESSES.
IT IS TRUE, I THINK AMERICA WAS
SLOW TO RECOGNIZE THIS
CHALLENGE, THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION, THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION DID NOT WANT TO
TOUCH IT.
THIS IS WHAT THE TECHNOLOGY IS
BEING USED FOR, HERE'S WHO YOU
ARE SELLING TO, THE SEPARATION
BETWEEN PRIVATE COMPANIES, THE
GOVERNMENT, DOESN'T EXIST THERE,
NOT REMOTELY LIKE WE HAVE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
WE HAVE MADE CLEAR TO THEM THAT
THEIR TECHNOLOGY IS BEING USED
IN WAYS THEY MAY NOT BE AWARE
OF, AND THE IMPACT, NOT ONLY THE
IMPACT IT HAS FOR AMERICAN
NATIONAL SECURITY, BUT THE
IMPACT ON THE BUSINESS AND THE
BUSINESS' REPUTATION IS VERY
REAL.
>> Laura: MR. SECRETARY, I
ALSO WANT YOUR REACTION TO
SOMETHING ONE OF YOUR
PREDECESSOR SAID LAST NIGHT ON
MSNBC.
WATCH.
>> WHY SHOULD RUSSIA HAVE ALL
THE FUN?
AND SINCE RUSSIA IS CLEARLY
PACKING REPUBLICANS, WHY DON'T
WE ASK CHINA TO BACK US?
NOT ONLY THAT, CHINA, IF YOU ARE
LISTENING, WHY DON'T YOU GET
TRUMP'S TAX RETURNS.
LET'S HAVE A GREAT POWER CONTEST
AND GET THE CHINESE IN ON THE
SIDE OF SOMEBODY ELSE.
>> Laura: LEADING DEMOCRAT,
SHE WAS ON FOR AN HOUR LAST
NIGHT.
THE GREAT POWER CONTEST, ASKING
CHINA TO DUMP THE TAX RETURNS.
>> THERE IS A GREAT POWER
CONTEST TAKING PLACE, I THINK
THAT IS TRUE.
I ONLY WISH QUINCY WAS SECRETARY
OF STATE, SHE WOULD'VE TAKEN IT
ON RATHER THAN ALLOWING
IT TO GET TO WHERE IT IS TODAY.
WE ARE TAKING THIS SERIOUSLY.
I HADN'T HEARD THOSE COMMENTS
BEFORE.
THEY DON'T REMOTELY SOUND LIKE
WHAT OUGHT TO BE DONE BY
AMERICANS, CERTAINLY NOT WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS GOING TO DO TO
MAKE SURE WE KEEP AMERICA SAFE,
RECOGNIZE CHINA HAS 1.5 BILLION
PEOPLE, THERE WILL BE COMMERCE
BETWEEN THE TWO COUNTRIES, AND
WE ARE TO MAKE SURE AMERICA IS
PREPARED SO WE CAN CONTINUE TO
BE THE WORLD'S LEADING POWER
TEN, 20, 50 YEARS FROM NOW.
>> Laura: ARE YOU HAVING MORE
FUN NOW THAN YOU WERE AS CIA
DIRECTOR?
IF I COULD CHOOSE BETWEEN ONE
AND THE OTHER, WHICH ONE IS MORE